- My expectations of pit bulls is
that they have scary teeth
and they are often guard dogs.
- I wanna believe that they are nice dogs.
I don't wanna be like a doggie racist.
- I'm excited-ish.
Kind of nervous-ish.
- This isn't something that I'm looking
forward to necessarily,
but I'm gonna do it.
I mean, I'm not a dog person,
so I don't know what
I'm supposed to do here.
Destroy it.
I feel very brave.
- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
- Oh, you are cute.
Look at that.
Why don't you smile?
- Come here, look.
- You don't look like you're
gonna bite my face off.
- High five.
Yeah, good job.
Pretty good dog.
- I always imagine them to be like these
really mean like drooling with the teeth.
- She doesn't move.
She didn't attack me.
I haven't even seen her teeth
and these are really soft.
- They're actually smaller than I thought.
I thought they were more ...
I thought they were just like those
really big muscle dogs,
but they seem so tiny.
- Oh, but I can rub your tummy.
I'm being super creepy right now.
- I don't have anymore treats.
I just have crumbs on my hands.
- Yeah, high five.
What a ...
Okay, they're good dogs.
What do ...
- That would suck, huh?
To like walk around and everyone's
kind of scared of you.
- I thought she would be like way bigger
and like have smaller ears
and just like constantly
showing her teeth.
- I like pit bulls.
Or I like these two pit bulls.
- They're very sweet
and I like them.
- Every dog is like a child.
You just have to raise it the right way.